from an understanding perspective
there's the richard feynman may be
attributed to him but maybe many others
is this idea that if you can't explain
something simply that you don't
understand it
in how many cases how often is that true
do you find there's some profound truth
in that
oh okay so you were about to ask is it
true to which i would say flatly no but
then you said
you followed that up with is there some
profound truth in it
okay sure so there's some truth in it
but it's not true
[Laughter]
this is your mathematician answer the
truth that is in it
yeah is that learning to explain
something helps you
understand it um but real things are not
simple
yeah a few things are most are not um
and i don't to be honest i don't i mean
i don't we don't really know whether
feynman really said that right or
something like that is sort of
disputed but i don't think feynman could
have literally believed that
whether or not he said it and you know
he was the kind of guy i didn't know him
but i'm
reading his writing he liked to sort of
say stuff like stuff that sounded good
you know what i mean so it's it's
totally strikes me as the kind of thing
he could have said because he liked the
way
saying it made him feel but also knowing
that he didn't like literally mean
it well i definitely have stuff have a
lot of friends and i've
talked to a lot of physicists and they
do derive joy from
believing that they can explain stuff
simply or believing it's possible to
explain stuff simply
even when the explanation is not
actually that simple like i've
heard people think that the explanation
is simple and they do the explanation
and i think
it is simple but it's not capturing the
phenomena that we're discussing
it's capturing it somehow maps in their
mind but it's
it's taking as a starting point as an
assumption that there's a deep
knowledge and a deep understanding
that's that's actually
very complicated and the simplicity is
almost like a
almost like a poem about the more
complicated thing as opposed to
a distillation and i love poems but a
poem is not an explanation
well some people might disagree with
that but certainly from a mathematical
perspective no poet would disagree with
it
no poet would disagree you you don't
think there's some things that can only
be described
in precisely i said explanation i don't
think any poem
i don't think any poet would say their
poem is an explanation they might say
it's a description they might say it's
sort of capturing sort of
well some people might say the only
truth is like music
right that the the the not the only
truth but some truth can only be
expressed through art
and i mean that's the whole thing we're
talking about religion and myth and
there's some things that uh are limited
cognitive capabilities
and the tools of mathematics or the
tools of physics are just not going to
allow us to capture
like it's possible consciousness is one
of those things
yes that is definitely possible but i
would even say
look and consciousness is a thing about
which we're still in the dark as to
where
whether there's an explanation we would
we would understand it as an explanation
at all by the way okay i gotta give yeah
one more amazing poincare quote because
this guy just never stopped coming out
with great quotes that
um you know paul eredish another fellow
who appears in the book and by the way
he thinks about this notion of distance
of like
personal affinity kind of like what
you're talking about that kind of social
network and that
notion of distance that comes from that
so that's something that paul erdos did
well he thought about distances and
networks i guess he didn't probably he
didn't think about the social
that was fascinating and that's how it
started that story verdict number yeah
okay
but you know eredish was sort of famous
for saying and this is sort of along the
lines we were saying
he talked about the book capital t
capital b
the book and that's the book where god
keeps the right proof of every
theorem so when he saw a proof he really
liked it was like really elegant really
simple like that's from the book that's
like
you found one of the ones that's in the
book um
he wasn't the religious guy by the way
he referred to god as the supreme
fascist he was like uh
but somehow he was like i don't really
believe in god but i believe in god's
book i mean it was
um but poincare on the other hand
um and by the way there are other
methods hilda hudson is one who comes up
in this book she also kind of
saw math um she's one of the people who
sort of develops
um the disease model that we now use
that we use to sort of track pandemics
this sir model that sort of originally
comes from
her work with ronald ross but she was
also super super super devout
and she also sort of on the other side
of the religious coin was like yeah math
is how we communicate with god
she has a great all these people are
incredibly quotable she says you know
math isn't
the truth the things about mathematics
she's like they're not the most
important of god thoughts
but they're the only ones that we can
know precisely
so she's like this is the one place
where we get to sort of see what god's
thinking when we do
mathematics again not a fan of poetry or
music some people
say hendrix is like some some people say
chapter one of that book is mathematics
and then chapter two is like classic
rock all right so
like it's not clear that the i'm sorry
you just sent me off on a tangent just
imagining like eredish at a hendrick's
concert like trying to sort of figure
out if it was from
the book or not i was what i was coming
to was justice it but one point
said about this is he's like you know
if like this is all worked out in the
language of the divine and if a divine
being like came down and
told it to us we wouldn't be able to
understand it so it doesn't matter
so ponca ray was of the view that there
were things that were sort of like
inhumanly complex
and that was how they really were our
job is to figure out
the things that are not like that that
are not like that
you